io voglio bere vodka voglio fare bene a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fatti j quest'oggi stiamo
sull'heysel shadows ragazzo videogame
indie horror che mi ha colpito
tantissimo perché era a mio parere
sembra la la fusione tra tra minecraft
es lander c'è una cosa non ho mai visto
un videogame del genere erano neanche
capito bene che cazzo si deve fare
aspettate che iniziava così in una tenda
il menù era una tenda o hanno vinto già
con questo hanno vinto tutto per me è il
miglior indica abbia mai giocato già
solo per questo
vivono due per prendere le risorse di
luce e premi f per accendere la risorsa
di luce ok ragazzi non ho mai visto
perché c'è l'accendi pensato cos'è
quella roba da giu c'è qualcosa che
luccica di brutto devo andare a vedere e
tra l'altro ragazzi hanno ancora in
altra risorsa di luce come cosa devo
premere due gay ha dato alla torcia
semplice che perfetta ci siamo e io io
non ho neanche capito bene qual è il
nemico li sto gioco cos'è questa una
candela posso prenderla cazzola prendo
devo prendere fremo devo trovare tutte
le candele che sta vista foresta siano
ragazzi mi dice quante ne ovvero perché
se lo vada minchia non ha senso
cos'è questo
ragazzi ok ok aspettate da questo questo
non l'ho capita questo non l'ho capita
sarà quello ho perso
ho perso così mi ha spuntato
affrontassimo stracchino e sono morto ma
che cazzo successo video non è capito
cosa è successo mi ha sputato un tizio
non si che brutto che era poi mamma mi
aspetta un attimo cosa allora cesto con
oltre che cos'è star o una bottiglia
lohan che butta una ferma ferma lo ridà
bottiglia la prima la prima candela
cielo
la prima 6 a passo cui io adesso prendo
sta cosa aprendo ok vado via mi levo dai
[ __ ] fermi dzagoev sembrava più
brutto di quando mi alzo la mattina c'è
mio dio è una cosa impressionante c'è
un'altra bottiglia
ragazzi questo dovrebbe essere vodka
team a ragazzi se tipo quando arrivai io
lì non c'è una bottiglia tipo palme
nella fronte dove raccogliere queste
candele ma qualcuno mi spiega come cazzo
le trovo che non mi danno cioè non
nominano neanche il numerino non mi
dicono neanche quante sono potrebbero
essere 40.000 anche per quanto ne so io
che cosa devo fare cosa è quello una tra
un'altra bottiglietta perfetta dalla
vodka io voglio bere vodka voglio quando
ma vaffan tua sorta button a che non è
altro maledizione ragazzi io credo che
questo sia uno dei giochi horror più
assurdi che abbia mai giocato io non so
con che cazzo di criterio hanno tirato
fuori quel tizio ma mi fa cagare addosso
in una mamma prof
tra l'altro ma che cazzo dormino napo
resta così [ __ ] allora che io prendo
questo no io sono rimasto spa rimasto
traumatizzato cazzo io vi giuro che è
quello credo sia stato uno degli
spaventi più grandi che mi sia mai preso
un credo seriamente di essere mai preso
uno così è assurdo non me l'aspettavo ci
sarebbe stata l'ultima cosa prezzo di
gran dama si terrà tiro nell'occhio per
poi vedersi arrivi [ __ ] che cazzo
ride acquazzone di quelle un sorriso
quello addio
capovilla ti faccio fare dalla parte
all'altra alla foresta con ceffone space
center vogliamo smettere di fare il
pirla qui ragazzi devo devo riuscire
allora carminat io credo che si debba
risolvere sto gioco jazz non accendendo
la luce cioè nel senso io vado avanti
senza accendere la luce dovrei
nascondermi meglio però non vedo un
cazzo di niente come faccio ora amico
mio io io non vedo al arabi pazienza io
dovrei andare in giro senza accendere la
luce però non vedo un cazzo quindi
facciamo così allora io ho un accendino
è una torcia facciamo così io
l'accendino a te vuoi vieni qui io ti
accendo la sigaretta facciamo una
chiacchierata ma te ne stai fermo ok c'è
un'ombra che ok non so se riuscite a
vederla ma c'è un'ombra che si sta
muovendo
ok e io io io io io starò bene vado a
qualcuno allora prendi prendi musona ok
resa sia via del cazzo via dal cazzo
ragazzi ho visto qualcosa che non dovevo
vedere io non so se l'avete visto perché
troppo troppo troppo buio ma non dovevo
cos'è ragazzo trovato ho trovato la casa
dentro dentro dentro della free a mia
volta
ok no destro
alla fine cosa sei già fammi capire
ragazzi cantiamo una canzoncina tutti
insieme così ci tranquillizziamo il
testo schifo devo trovare cos'è save tra
i cake and spend a metterle qui io le
candele che prendo dove metterle tutte
qua sopra in cerchio certo come se non
bastasse prenderle devo anche metterla
in ordine non sanno preparare anche un
caffè non lo so di me lo è ma mi dici
dove cazzo sei dove cazzo andato ragazzi
che ho fatti io allora io sono anche un
[ __ ] però sto tizio non è che può
andasse in giro così allora io adesso
tipi io da dietro
ok forse allora volevo fargli uno
scherzetto ma mi sa che non vi conviene
bene corrieri in casa casa dove cazzo
era caso che questa finiti questi
ragazzi ci siamo ci siamo ci siamo qik
assaggiati analizzò fra ragazzi ok c'è
qualcuno piano di sopra che ho visto ciò
campioni sopra che ho visto che prende
qualcosa mi sento ancora mi segue più
non mi segue più non mi è sparito di
brutto e va bene così
va bene che vada mila bottiglie veloce
veloce che il cazzo raccolto tra l'altro
ragazzi ma ma secondo arriva al tizio il
rilancio la bottiglia se ne va a fan
culo perché potete potrebbe anche essere
sapete non lo so che infatti ne so prova
a fare così come si lanciava bottiglie
non mi ricordo
ok ok prendi la prendi la prendi la
prendiate
luca ok ragazzi ho trovato ho trovato il
modo trovato il modo me non può più fare
tutto ragazzi ho trovato fermi le
bottiglie sono la mia salvezza ragazzi
devo vederlo arrivare però un casino
come cazzo volete arrivare spiega c'è
un'attenzione addosso della madonna tra
prendi sta roba prendi veloce ragazzino
non so se ho abbastanza che annunciano
ancora una ragione ci arriverò mai
laggiù vivo mi ammazzano prima e cazzo è
sta roba
due sono usa un campo di grano cos'è una
merda sono state 12 le sabbie mobili
notiamo pure nella merda per raggiungere
le torce massi chissenefrega tanto poi
lava la mamma i panni chissenefrega
ragazzi dove cazzo siamo la missione è
impossibile l'articolato andava portato
in salvo e c'è la parola portare le
candele di nuovo al circolo perché sennò
non finisce il gioco dove riuscirà
pinter e che se vuoi adesso a [ __ ]
lancio il monitor
ma non è possibile allora numero uno e
ci siamo perfetti in qui e non ci sia
già arrivata anche prima ragazzi ho
ritrovato circolo poliziotto c ok allora
mettiamo mettiamo le lanterne da bravi
c'è nessuno vero bene così allora
mettiamo mettile cametti se lanterne
[ __ ] veloce veloce quante me ne
mancano una una un amen e marco l'ho
vista prima l'ho visto prima
dov'era ragazzi l'ho vista prima non
sono pazzo eccola ragazzi ne manca una
le manca un lato dove andrebbe devo
andare e tornare andare e tornare
fucking andare fucking tornare
ok dove cazzo avevo perso un millimetro
e l'offesa ok ok ok modo non approvato
avvicinarsi qualcuno provi ero vicino si
colora lancia a terra lo stesso
[ __ ] ho vinto ho vinto ho vinto
ragazzi tutti le mani su in cielo per il
genchi lava aiutiamo goku ok ok ok ho
vinto la mia ho vinto veramente
bastardo che timori se pettirosso e
ricordati che tua sorella una [ __ ]
come ho detto all'inizio del video
ragazzi io non so perché ho giocato
questa roba è impossibile o di johann le
lanterne c'erano tutte concludo qui
l'episodio perché trent'anni di vita me
li sono giocati con gli importi sono
convinto comunque ragazzi per 66 video
vi è piaciuto lasciate un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook che
come non i video trovate nella
descrizione iscritti iscrivetevi ci
vediamo al prossimo video e ragazzi